todavía no se ve muchos electores es que
en realidad el clima que se vive en perú
es de un país polarizado más de 25
millones de ciudadanos van a salir al
sufragar en esta segunda vuelta que está
salpicado por rumores psicosociales y
campañas de ataque entre uno y otro
partido político a esto se ha sumado
también enfrentamientos diversos
analistas ha dicho que esta polarización
va a llevar al final de resultados a que
el candidato o los simpatizantes de la
propuesta que pierda va a ser reclamos y
esto podría extenderse en los siguientes
días a que se den a conocer los
resultados oficiales por la oficina
nacional de procesos electorales del
perú